hello everyone and welcome to the pod on
today's episode we are joined by graeme
jennings who is the senior producer
behind hyperscape
and we're also joined by tanner slaves
who is not only a part of the very first
hyper escape twitch rivals tournament
but also placed second in this past
weekend's 50 thousand dollar
creator cup they're going to be helping
us break down hyperscape from the very
first things you should be learning
all the way to high level tournament
plays let's get to it
hyperscape is officially available
everywhere but
some players are still dropping in for
the very first time so graeme can you
give us some tips on what players should
be learning
first and what the most important thing
is when you are dropping into the
hyperscape i think the key things for
players for the first time they play is
really
you want to land close to where your
lobby is so basically
the games split out into four lobbies at
the game start so you want to land on a
point that's fairly low
and close to you that will allow you to
get there first and you're likely to
have less opposition
from there you want to quickly look for
a weapon so you can smash the barricades
with your battle and start to look for a
weapon you want to pick up a weapon
early
secondly to that we have the function
called hacks they're basically abilities
for players to be able to use
it's good to pick up a hack quickly as
well things like
teleport invisibility slam or things
that add to your movement to keep you
safe in the early game so you need to
make sure you're armed early and you
need to make sure you have a hack with
you as well
and from your point of view tanner what
are some tournament tips you can give
for those players who are trying to get
those next level strategies
so if you want a safe landing to make
sure that you can land get your weapons
your hacks
and make sure your team is together um
safely you can
all land straight down below or what we
were doing in the creator cup and in
other competitions where
we would land somewhat center of the map
that way we one could get on top of red
tiger
which is a location in the center to
offer kind of vantage points around
uh the entire map to see where straight
bullets are going or
if a team two teams are fighting to
where we can kind of get involved a
little bit early
i would recommend off the start
something with mobility especially in
these competitions where people are
being eliminated really really really
quick off the start
uh so teleport obviously closes the
distance can be used offensively or
defensively
slam you can basically pull yourself up
into the air
and it's really great for one like
looking around the entire map to see if
teams are fighting and you can see you
know a bird's eye view of where
everybody's at
and then you can secondly when you
complete your slam you slam down and do
extra damage to other players
invisibility is incredibly strong for if
you say get caught off guard so if you
get shot in the back
or kind of get caught off guard and
someone surprises you you can always
activate your invisibility and kind of
relocate reposition yourself
with eel heel offers really good sustain
when team fighting
there's quite a few matches where we ran
into other tournament teams
you know having that extra heel creates
that kind of sustain
to eventually win the fight or we could
relocate and reposition to give us a
better
chance to win the game obviously once
you get those core gameplay mechanics
honed and ready
you're gonna want to look into weapons
and hacks so
for you graeme what are some weapons and
hacks that you not only love to use
personally
but that you designed so for me in terms
of my favorite loadout i really
i'm a kind of short range player i like
to use the mammoth shotgun
which is really useful especially when
paired with teleport you can teleport up
be right on the player and shotgun them
at really close range secondly to that i
like to use the harpy harpy's kind of a
super fast rate
submachine gun same thing that's really
good when paired with
teleport or paired with invisibility
allows you to get up really close to
your enemy player and eliminate them
in terms of the weapons that we design
which i think are cool you know from dez
town
i really like the sky breaker it's
really interesting it fires this big
ball of energy you know you can see them
flying across the map and if you're good
enough to
land on someone it does a lot of damage
it's really interesting to see
these bolts fly towards you from other
rooftops and you're kind of dodging and
moving as you're shooting back at the
other players
and for you tanner have you noticed any
optimal loadouts or optimal combinations
that
really secure those tournament wins
personally i like to use
the ripper i've always been an assault
rifle player when it comes to fps games
so when you start out and you land
and get your core weapons of what you
want to level up when you find
duplicates of those weapons you can fuse
them together
majority of them you get magazine
increases and then on the final upgrade
you get a damage increase so it's really
crucial and important
to uh fuse the duplicates of your
loadout
uh to make them stronger and better so
primary i would say the ripper and then
myself
i really like using the riot one um
the damage output the more and more that
you level it up
uh is vital teleport and
like heal was a really good loadout to
run so the more and more that you fuse
the same thing goes along with your
hacks as well if you find the same hack
uh you can duplicate it to then reduce
the cooldown of your hack so you can
teleport more or heal your team more so
you know it's crucial to
find those duplicates now the game has
been
in the hands of the players for a little
bit over a week now
is there anything surprising that you've
seen the community
discover and learn or develop or any
tactics that you're shocked to see
i think two of the key things have been
really interesting one's people's usage
of wall
like we always thought about wall to
block someone in or to protect yourself
from behind
people are using it as a mobility hack
now as well they're throwing the wall on
the ground it teleports them up in the
air
and then they use that as mobility on
top so that's been really interesting
second one is the popularity of slam
like we knew slam was good
it allows you to be offensive or
defensive you can escape a gunfight by
projecting up in the air you can also
project up and slam down on an enemy but
it's been really really popular i think
it's almost in everybody's loadout so
that one's been really interesting to
see i think secondly to that is really
the popularity of the riot one pistol we
see a lot of players using
a sniper rifle for long-range tactics
but they also
seem to pair it with the riot one two so
they'll snipe the enemy a couple of
times or
once and then they'll finish them off
with the right one pistol so that one's
been super super popular as well
before you go green we wanted to finish
things off with something a little more
fun
and that was to collect some community
plays and get your reactions from it
because
we've seen some pretty cool stuff so far
so let's roll those clips
i see he's rocking the loadout the uh
the riot one mammoth
here's a good use of slime he's managed
to project himself up to the top of the
building and he's chased the player down
good slam right here to contest this
person on height he follows him down
with a mama's shotgun
stands right beside him has a good look
at him this player just has no
idea where he's at what's happening
around him
that was hilarious to see him just kind
of like looking around hopelessly like
i hope he doesn't know where i am you
know here this is a nice clip we really
see some interest in interior combat
you've seen the player with the
upper vantage retreat a little bit taken
some damage gone upstairs
so you notice that he's got wall heel
this is one of those like sustaining
loadouts but you'll see he's been
really smart he's left a little gap at
the bottom of the wall oh no
he goes for the toe shots he walls off
the
entire building right here uh and
there's a little
little advantageous uh opening there and
he he takes this player out
shooting the toes so this loadout
i'm already noticing skybreaker komodo
makes it really hard to
challenge players up close especially
being indoors too
explosives are incredibly strong the
lethal melee
event is happening right now both of his
teammates are eliminated so
everyone's watching this go down right
now that's actually really awesome great
use of the
armor there armor heal if he gets
outnumbered inside he can use the heel
in
you know for the sustain and when he's
outnumbered
outside or as you saw other players were
attacking him
the full squad wipes an entire team with
only a melee the
melee events are extremely terrifying
because your game is on like
that's your tournament on the line and
you don't want to just die to
melee attacks so you have to be
situationally aware of what event is out
obviously when it comes to strategy and
it comes to high level plays
we had to get tanner to break down one
of his own plays
from this past weekend during the
creator cup so we got this clip
for you tanner and we need to hear your
breakdown on it
take it away so we landed uh helios
inside of the uh or outside of the
um you know general structure of helios
we go to the solar panels there's a
player that
i kind of see that's approaching me
pretty aggressively
and i knew that he had the advantage so
i wanted to disengage from that fight
you see me go up to top helios and call
that out now my team
uh comes in saves me i do have
invisibility to
kind of prolong this guy wondering where
the heck i went
um and so then we take this guy out now
here i'm just looking for
any upgrades any ammo as you see here my
teammate called out like a riot one and
we were talking about that earlier how
incredibly important it is to use your
weapons together so i get that fused up
right there
um and i already hear more shots more
call-outs that they're
enemy teams fighting so here this is
what i love about the ripper now
personally i love being a support player
so any target that i see
i'm going to be putting shots down range
as you can see here i'm focusing down
low and then immediately acknowledge
another player up top
um and then just kind of transition from
there and then there's just so much
loot scattered on the ground as you see
here i kind of take a slow time of
making sure that i'm not leaving any
fuse ups behind
and we go on to uh finish the fight
finish the game
that's all for today you guys thank you
so much graeme and tanner for joining us
sharing your insight and having a great
time
for everyone watching from home make
sure you're here next week because we
are diving even deeper
into hyperscape and we are going to be
showing off some more of your community
highlights so make sure you're
submitting those using
hyperscape but before you go don't
forget we have
another memory shard hint for you check
it out
you